what I hope to do in this video is go
through a bunch of examples that will
hopefully give us some even better
understanding of what it means to add or
subtract a positive or a negative number
and as I go through these I encourage
you to keep pausing the video and trying
to solve it on your own and then see how
we can solve it together so let's start
if I were to say that negative 1 is
equal to 7 minus blank what should be in
that blank what number either positive
or negative I guess it could be 0 what
would that number be all right let's
work through it together so let me throw
a number line here so let me put a
number line right over here and let's
just think about what's going on so we
are trying to get to negative 1 we're
trying to get to negative 1 and we are
starting at 7 so 7 this is 5 6 7 so
we're starting at 7 so what do we have
to subtract from 7 to get 2 to get to
this negative 1 here well we have to
move we have to move 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8
to the left so what we just did is we
just subtracted we just subtracted 8
from 7 to get to negative 1 so what do
we need to subtract we just subtract we
need to subtract 8 let's do another one
of these this is kind of fun let's say
we need to figure out let's say we have
negative 10 plus blank is equal to
negative 5 what would the blank be in
this case let's give ourselves a number
line again so let's give ourselves a
number line again and let's see we are
going to start at negative 10 so let's
see this is negative 10 right over here
so we're going to start at negative 10
and we're going to add something to it
to get to negative 5 remember negative 5
is right over here
so for adding that means we're going to
be going to the right on the number line
that is if we're adding a positive
number and we see here we're going to
the right we're going from negative 10
to negative 5 so we are going to be
adding a positive number if we add as a
negative number we would move to the
left so how much are we adding well
let's just count we're going to add one
two three four five so we just added we
just added positive five so that would
be a five right there negative ten plus
five is equal to negative five we just
became five less negative is one way to
think about it let's do another one all
right so let's say we had four is equal
to negative two plus blank four is equal
to negative two plus blank well we can
do this the same way we've been doing
others let's get our number line out
here let's get our number line out here
and let's see we're going to one way to
think about our goal is to get to four
our goal is 4 right over here so this is
1 2 3 4 get to positive 4 that's
positive 4 right there we're starting at
negative 2 we're starting it I'm just in
a different color we're starting at
negative 2 we're saying 4 is the same
thing as negative 2 negative 2 is right
over here negative 2 plus some amount
and it's clear we're going to be moving
to the right by let's see we're going to
move to the right by 1 2 3 4 5 6 so we
moved to the right by 6 so we added 6 so
negative 2 plus 6 plus 6 is equal to 4
this is fascinating
let's do that's just let's just do
several more of these I can't stop all
right so let's say we wanted to figure
out let's say we wanted to figure out I
have 6 plus blank 6 plus blank is equal
to negative 8 like always try to pause
the video and figure out what this blank
is going to be let me throw my number
line back here so my number line and one
way to think about it one way to think
about it is I am starting at 6
I'm starting at 6 so that's 5 this is 6
right over here and I'm going to add
something to get to negative 8 to get to
negative 8 this is negative 5 negative 6
negative 7 negative 8 I want to get
right over here I want to get to
negative 8 so what do I have to do to
get from 6 to negative 8 to go from 6 to
negative 8
well it's clear I have to go to the left
on the number line and how much do I
have to go to the left well let's count
it I have to go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14
so going 14 to the left you could say
that I just subtracted 14 and if we
phrase it as 6 plus what is equal to
negative 8 well 6 plus negative 14 6 if
this said 6 minus something I could have
just said 6 minus 14 but I'm saying 6
plus 1 is going to be 6 plus negative 14